OK, here's the last lecture in
the chapter on orthogonality.
So we met orthogonal
vectors, two vectors,
we met orthogonal subspaces,
like the row space and null
space.
Now today we meet
an orthogonal basis,
and an orthogonal matrix.
So we really --
this chapter cleans
up orthogonality.
And really I want --
I should use the
word orthonormal.
Orthogonal is -- so my
vectors are q1,q2 up to qn --
I use the letter "q",
here, to remind me,
I'm talking about orthogonal
things, not just any vectors,
but orthogonal ones.
So what does that mean?
That means that every q is
orthogonal to every other q.
It's a natural idea,
to have a basis that's
headed off at
ninety-degree angles,
the inner products are all zero.
Of course if q is -- certainly
qi is not orthogonal to itself.
But there we'll make
the best choice again,
make it a unit vector.
Then qi transpose qi is
one, for a unit vector.
The length squared is one.
And that's what I would
use the word normal.
So for this part, normalized,
unit length for this part.
OK.
So first part of
the lecture is how
does having an orthonormal
basis make things nice?
It certainly does.
It makes all the
calculations better,
a whole lot of
numerical linear algebra
is built around working
with orthonormal vectors,
because they never
get out of hand,
they never overflow
or underflow.
And I'll put them
into a matrix Q,
and then the second
part of the lecture
will be suppose my
basis, my columns of A
are not orthonormal.
How do I make them so?
And the two names associated
with that simple idea
are Graham and Schmidt.
So the first part is we've
got a basis like this.
Let's put those into
the columns of a matrix.
So a matrix Q that has --
I'll put these
orthonormal vectors,
q1 will be the first column,
qn will be the n-th column.
And I want to say, I want
to write this property,
qi transpose qj
being zero, I want
to put that in a matrix form.
And just the right thing is
to look at Q transpose Q.
So this chapter has been
looking at A transpose A.
So it's natural to
look at Q transpose Q.
And the beauty is it
comes out perfectly.
Because Q transpose has
these vectors in its rows,
the first row is q1 transpose,
the nth row is qn transpose.
So that's Q transpose.
And now I want to multiply by Q.
That has q1 along to
qn in the columns.
That's Q.
And what do I get?
You really -- this is the
first simplest most basic fact,
that how do orthonormal
vectors, orthonormal columns
in a matrix, what happens
if I compute Q transpose Q?
Do you see it?
If I take the first row
times the first column,
what do I get?
A one.
If I take the first row
times the second column,
what do I get?
Zero.
That's the orthogonality.
The first row times the
last column is zero.
And so I'm getting
ones on the diagonal
and I'm getting zeroes
everywhere else.
I'm getting the identity matrix.
You see how that's -- it's
just like the right calculation
to do.
If you have orthonormal
columns, and the matrix
doesn't have to be square here.
We might have just two columns.
And they might have
four, lots of components.
So but they're orthonormal, and
when we do Q transpose times Q,
that Q transpose times
Q or A transpose A
just asks for all
those dot products.
Rows times columns.
And in this orthonormal case,
we get the best possible answer,
the identity.
OK, so this is --
so I mean now we have a new
bunch of important matrices.
What have we seen previously?
We've seen in the
distant past we
had triangular matrices,
diagonal matrices, permutation
matrices, that was
early chapters,
then we had row echelon
forms, then in this chapter
we've already seen
projection matrices,
and now we're seeing this
new class of matrices
with orthonormal columns.
That's a very long expression.
I sorry that I can't just
call them orthogonal matrices.
But that word
orthogonal matrices --
or maybe I should be able to
call it orthonormal matrices,
why don't we call
it orthonormal --
I mean that would be an
absolutely perfect name.
For Q, call it an
orthonormal matrix
because its columns
are orthonormal.
OK, but the convention is
that we only use that name
orthogonal matrix,
we only use this --
this word orthogonal,
we don't even
say orthonormal for
some unknown reason,
matrix when it's square.
So in the case when this is a
square matrix, that's the case
we call it an orthogonal matrix.
And what's special about
the case when it's square?
When it's a square matrix,
we've got its inverse, so --
so in the case if Q is square,
then Q transpose Q equals I
tells us --
let me write that underneath --
tells us that Q
transpose is Q inverse.
There we have the
easy to remember
property for a square matrix
with orthonormal columns.
That -- I need to write
some examples down.
Let's see.
Some examples like if I
take any -- so examples,
let's do some examples.
Any permutation matrix,
let me take just
some random permutation matrix.
Permutation Q equals let's say
oh, make it three by three,
say zero, zero, one, one,
zero, zero, zero, one, zero.
OK.
That certainly has unit
vectors in its columns.
Those vectors are certainly
perpendicular to each other.
And if I -- and so that's it.
That makes it a Q.
And -- if I took its transpose,
if I multiplied by Q transpose,
shall I do that -- and let
me stick in Q transpose
here.
Just to do that
multiplication once more,
transpose it'll put the --
make that into a column,
make that into a column.
And the transpose is also --
another Q.
Another orthonormal matrix.
And when I multiply that
product I get I. OK,
so there's an example.
And actually there's
a second example.
But those are real
easy examples, right,
I mean to get orthogonal
columns by just
putting ones in different
places is like too easy.
So let me keep
going with examples.
So here's another
simple example.
Cos theta sine theta,
there's a unit vector,
oh, let me even
take it, well, yeah.
Cos theta sine theta
and now the other way
I want sine theta cos theta.
But I want the inner
product to be zero.
And if I put a minus
there, it'll do it.
So that's -- unit vector,
that's a unit vector.
And if I take the dot product,
I get minus plus zero.
OK.
For example Q equals say
one, one, one, minus one,
is that an orthogonal matrix?
I've got orthogonal
columns there,
but it's not quite
an orthogonal matrix.
How shall I fix it to
be an orthogonal matrix?
Well, what's the length
of those column vectors,
the dot product with themselves
is -- right now it's two,
right, the --
the length squared.
The length squared would be
one plus one would be two,
the length would be
square root of two,
so I better divide by
square root of two.
OK.
So there's a -- there now I
have got an orthogonal matrix,
in fact, it's this one --
when theta is pi over four.
The cosines and
well almost, I guess
the minus sine is down
there, so maybe, I
don't know, maybe minus
pi over four or something.
OK.
Let me do one
final example, just
to show that you
can get bigger ones.
Q equals let me take that
matrix up in the corner
and I'll sort of
repeat that pattern,
repeat it again, and
then minus it down here.
That's one of the world's
favorite orthogonal matrices.
I hope I got it right, is --
can you see whether --
if I take the inner product of
one column with another one,
let's see, if I take
the inner product
of that column with that I have
two minuses and two pluses,
that's good.
When I take the inner
product of that with that
I have a plus and a
minus, a minus and a plus.
Good.
I think it all works out.
And what do I have
to divide by now?
To make those into unit vectors.
Right now the vector one,
one, one, one has length two.
Square root of four.
So I have to divide by two
to make it unit vector,
so there's another.
That's my entire array
of simple examples.
This construction is named after
a guy called Adhemar and we
know how to do it for
two, four, sixteen,
sixty-four and so on, but we --
nobody knows exactly which size
matrices have --
which size -- which sizes allow
orthogonal matrices of ones
and minus ones.
So Adhemar matrix is an
orthogonal matrix that's got
ones and minus ones, and a
lot of ones -- some we know,
some other sizes, there couldn't
be a five by five I think.
But there are some
sizes that nobody
yet knows whether there could be
or can't be a matrix like that.
OK.
You see those
orthogonal matrices.
Now let me ask what -- why
is it good to have orthogonal
matrices?
What calculation is made easy?
If I have an orthogonal matrix.
And -- let me remember that the
matrix could be rectangular.
Shall I put down --
I better put a
rectangular example down.
So the -- these were
all square examples.
Can I put down just --
a rectangular one
just to be sure
that we realize that
this is possible.
let's help me out.
Let's see, if I put like a
one, two, two and a minus two,
minus one, two.
That's -- a matrix -- oh its
columns aren't normalized yet.
I always have to
remember to do that.
I always do that last
because it's easy to do.
What's the length
of those columns?
So if I wanted them -- if I
wanted them to be length one,
I should divide by their
length, which is --
so I'd look at one squared plus
two squared plus two squared,
that's one and four
and four is nine,
so I take the square root and
I need to divide by three.
OK.
So there is --
well, without that, I've
got one orthonormal vector.
I mean just one unit vector.
Now put that guy in.
Now I have a basis
for the column
space for a two-dimensional
space, an orthonormal basis,
right?
These two columns
are orthonormal,
they would be an
orthonormal basis
for this two-dimensional
space that they span.
Orthonormal vectors by the way
have got to be independent.
It's easy to show that
orthonormal vectors
since they're headed off
all at ninety degrees
there's no combination
that gives zero.
Now if I wanted to
create now a third one,
I could either just put in
some third vector that was
independent and go to this
Graham-Schmidt calculation that
I'm going to explain, or I
could be inspired and say look,
that -- with that pattern,
why not put a one in there,
and a two in there,
and try to fix up the
signs so that they worked.
Hmm.
I don't know if I've done
this too brilliantly.
Let's see, what
signs, that's minus,
maybe I'd make a minus sign
there, how would that be?
Yeah, maybe that works.
I think that those three columns
are orthonormal and they --
the beauty of this -- this is
the last example I'll probably
find where there's no
square root, the --
the punishing thing
in Graham-Schmidt,
maybe we better know
that in advance,
is that because I want these
vectors to be unit vectors,
I'm always running
into square roots.
I'm always dividing by lengths.
And those lengths
are square roots.
So you'll see as soon as I
do a Graham-Schmidt example,
square roots are
going to show up.
But here are some
examples where we did it
without any square root.
OK.
So -- so great.
Now next question is what's
the good of having a Q?
What formulas become easier?
Suppose I want to
project, so suppose Q --
suppose Q has
orthonormal columns.
I'm using the letter
Q to mean this,
I'll write it this
one more time,
but I always mean
when I write a Q,
I always mean that it
has orthonormal columns.
So suppose I want to project
onto its column space.
So what's the projection matrix?
What's the projection matrix is
I project onto a column space?
OK, that gives me a chance to
review the projection section,
including that big formula,
which used to be --
those four As in a
row, but now it's
got Qs, because I'm projecting
onto the column space of Q,
so do you remember what it was?
It's Q Q transpose Q
inverse Q transpose.
That's my four Qs in a row.
But what's good here?
What -- what makes this formula
nice if I'm projecting onto
a column space when I have
orthonormal basis for that
space?
What makes it nice is
this is the identity.
I don't have to
do any inversion.
I just get Q Q transpose.
So Q Q transpose is
a projection matrix.
Oh, I can't help --
I can't resist just
checking the properties,
what are the properties
of a projection matrix?
There are two properties to
know for any projection matrix.
And I'm saying that this
is the right projection
matrix when we've got
this orthonormal basis
in the columns.
OK.
So there's the
projection matrix.
Suppose the matrix is square.
First just tell me
first this extreme case.
If my matrix is square and it's
got these orthonormal columns,
then what's the column space?
If I have a square matrix and
I have independent columns,
and even orthonormal columns,
then the column space
is the whole space, right?
And what's the projection
matrix onto the whole space?
The identity matrix.
If I'm projecting
in the whole space,
every vector B is right
where it's supposed to be
and I don't have to
move it by projection.
So this would be --
I'll put in parentheses
this is I if Q is square.
Well that we said that already.
If Q is square, that's the case
where Q transpose is Q inverse,
we can put it on the right,
we can put it on the left,
we always get the identity
matrix, if it's square.
But if it's not a square
matrix then it's not --
we don't get the
identity matrix.
We have Q Q transpose,
and just again
what are those two properties
of a projection matrix?
First of all, it's symmetric.
OK, no problem, that's
certainly a symmetric So what's
that second property
of a projection?
matrix.
That if you project and project
again you don't move the second
time.
So the other property
of a projection matrix
should be that Q
Q transpose twice
should be the same as
Q Q transpose once.
That's projection matrices.
And that property
better fall out
right away because
from the fact we
know about orthonormal matrices,
Q transpose Q is I. OK,
you see it.
In the middle here is sitting
Q Q t- Q transpose Q, sorry,
that's what I meant to
say, Q transpose Q is I.
So that's sitting right in
the middle, that cancels out,
to give the identity, we're
left with one Q Q transpose,
and we're all set.
OK.
So this is the
projection matrix --
all the equation -- all the
messy equations of this chapter
become trivial
when our matrix --
when we have this
orthonormal basis.
I mean what do I mean
by all the equations?
Well, the most
important equation
was the normal equation, do
you remember old A transpose
A x hat equals A transpose b?
But now -- now A is Q.
Now I'm thinking I have
Q transpose Q X hat
equals Q transpose b.
And what's good about that?
What's good is that matrix on
the left side is the identity.
The matrix on the left is
the identity, Q transpose Q,
normally it isn't, normally it's
that matrix of inner products
and you've to compute all those
dopey inner products and --
and -- and solve the system.
Here the inner products
are all one or zero.
This is the identity matrix.
It's gone.
And there's the answer.
There's no inversion involved.
Each component of
x is a Q times b.
What that equation is saying
is that the i-th component is
the i-th basis vector times b.
That's -- probably the most
important formula in some major
parts of mathematics, that
if we have orthonormal basis,
then the component in the --
in the i-th, along the i-th --
the projection on the i-th basis
vector is just qi transpose b.
That number x that we look
for is just a dot product.
OK.
OK, so I'm ready now for
the sort of like second half
of the lecture.
Where we don't start with
an orthogonal matrix,
orthonormal vectors.
We just start with
independent vectors
and we want to make
them orthonormal.
So I'm going to --
can I do that now?
Now here comes Graham-Schmidt.
So -- Graham-Schmidt.
So this is a calculation,
I won't say --
I can't quite say it's like
elimination, because it's
different, our goal
isn't triangular anymore.
With elimination our goal was
make the matrix triangular.
Now our goal is make
the matrix orthogonal.
Make those columns orthonormal.
So let me start
with two columns.
So I start with vectors a and b.
And they're just like --
here, let me draw them.
Here's a.
Here's b.
For example.
A isn't specially
horizontal, wasn't
meant to be, just a is
one vector, b is another.
I want to produce
those two vectors,
they might be in
twelve-dimensional space,
or they might be in
two-dimensional space.
They're independent, anyway.
So I better be sure I say that.
I start with
independent vectors.
And I want to produce
out of that q 1 and q2,
I want to produce
orthonormal vectors.
And Graham and
Schmidt tell me how.
OK.
Well, actually you could tell me
how, we don't need -- frankly,
I don't know -- there's
only one idea here,
if Graham had the idea, I
don't know what Schmidt did.
But OK.
So you'll see it.
We don't need either
of them, actually.
OK, so what I going to do.
I'll take that --
this first guy.
OK.
Well, he's fine.
That direction is fine except --
yeah, I'll say OK, I'll
settle for that direction.
So I'm going to --
I'm going to get, so
what I going to --
my goal is I'm going to
get orthogonal vectors
and I'll call those
capital A and B.
So that's the key step is
to get from any two vectors
to two orthogonal vectors.
And then at the end, no problem,
I'll get orthonormal vectors,
how will -- what will those
will be my qs, q1 and q2,
and what will they
be?
Once I've got A and B
orthogonal, well, look,
it's no big deal -- maybe
that's what Schmidt did, he,
brilliant Schmidt, thought
OK, divide by the length,
all right.
That's Schmidt's contribution.
OK.
But Graham had a little
more thinking to do, right?
We haven't done Graham's part.
This part except OK,
I'm happy with A,
A can be A. That first
direction is fine.
Why should -- no
complaint about that.
The trouble is the second
direction is not fine.
Because it's not
orthogonal to the first.
I'm looking for a vector
that's -- starts with B,
but makes it orthogonal to A.
What's the vector?
How do I do that?
How do I produce
from this vector
a piece that's
orthogonal to this one?
And the -- remember these
vectors might be in two
dimensions or they might
be in twelve dimensions.
I'm just looking for the idea.
So what's the idea?
Where did we have orthogonal --
a vector showing up that
was orthogonal to this guy?
Well, that was the
first basic calculation
of the whole chapter.
We -- we did a projection and
the projection gave us this
part, which was the
part in the A direction.
Now, the part we want is
the other part, the e part.
This part.
This is going to be our --
that guy is that guy.
This is our vector B. That gives
us that ninety-degree angle.
So B is you could say --
B is really what we
previously called
e.
The error vector.
And what is it?
I mean what do I
-- what is B here?
A is A, no problem.
B is --
OK, what's this error piece?
Do you remember?
It's I start with the original
B and I take away what?
Its projection, this P.
This -- the vector B,
this error vector, is the
original vector removing
the projection.
So instead of wanting
the projection,
now that's what I
want to throw away.
I want to get the part
that's perpendicular.
And there will be a
perpendicular part,
it won't be zero.
Because these vectors
were independent, so B --
if B was along the
direction of A,
then if the original B and A
were in the same direction,
then I'm --
I've only got one direction.
But here they're in two
independent directions
and all I'm doing
is getting that guy.
So what's its formula?
What's the formula
for that if --
I want to subtract
the projection,
so do you remember
the projection?
It's some multiple of A
and what's that multiple?
It's -- it's that thing we
called x in the very very first
lecture on this chapter.
There's an A transpose
A in the bottom
and there's an A transpose
B, isn't that it?
I think that's Graham's formula.
Or Graham-Schmidt.
No, that's Graham.
Schmidt has got to divide the
whole thing by the length,
so he --
his formula makes a mess which
I'm not willing to write down.
So let's just see that
what I saying here?
I'm saying that this vector
is perpendicular to A.
That these are orthogonal.
A is perpendicular to B.
Can you check that?
How do you see that
yes, of course, we --
our picture is telling
us, yes, we did it right.
How would I check that this
matrix is perpendicular to A?
I would multiply by A transpose
and I better get zero, right?
I should check that.
A transpose B should
come out zero.
So this is A transpose times
-- now what did we say B was?
We start with the original
B, and we take away
this projection, and that
should come out zero.
Well, here we get an
A transpose B minus --
and here is another A
transpose B, and the --
and it's an A transpose A
over A transpose A, a one,
those cancel, and
we do get zero.
Right.
Now I guess I can
do numbers in there.
But I have to take
a third vector
to be sure we've got
this system down.
So now I have to say if I have
independent vectors A, B and C,
I'm looking for orthogonal
vectors A, B and capital C,
and then of course the
third guy will just
be C over its length,
the unit vector.
So this is now the problem.
I got B here.
I got A very easily.
And now -- if you see the idea,
we could figure out a formula
for C. So now that -- so this
is like a typical homework quiz
problem.
I give you two vectors, you do
this, I give you three vectors,
and you have to make
them orthonormal.
So you do this again,
the first vector's fine,
the second vector is
perpendicular to the first,
and now I need a
third vector that's
perpendicular to the first
one and the second one.
Right?
Tthis is the end of a -- the
lecture is to find this guy.
Find this vector -- this vector
C, that's perpendicular we n-
at this point we know A and B.
But C, the little c that
we're given, is off in some --
it's got to come out of the
blackboard to be independent,
so -- so can I sort of draw
off -- off comes a c somewhere.
I don't know, where I
going to put the darn
thing?
Maybe I'll put it
off, oh, I don't know,
like that somehow, C, little c.
And I already know that
perpendicular direction,
that one and that one.
So now what's the idea?
Give me the Graham-Schmidt
formula for C.
What is this C here?
Equals what?
What I going to do?
I'll start with the given one.
As before.
Right?
I start with the
vector I'm given.
And what do I do with it?
I want to remove out of
it, I want to subtract off,
so I'll put a minus sign
in, I want to subtract off
its components in the A, capital
A and capital B directions.
I just want to get
those out of there.
Well, I know how to do that.
I did it with B.
So I'll just -- so
let me take away --
what if I do this?
What have I done?
I've got little c and what
have I subtracted from it?
Its component, its projection
if you like, in the A direction.
And now I've got to subtract
off its component B transpose
C over B transpose B,
that multiple of B,
is its component
in the B direction.
And that gives me the vector
capital C that if anything is
--
if there's any justice, this
C should be perpendicular to A
and it should be
perpendicular to B.
And the only thing it's --
hasn't got is unit vector,
so we divide by its
length to get that too.
OK.
Let me do an example.
Can I --
I'll make my life easy,
I'll just take two vectors.
So let me do a
numerical example.
If I'll give you
two vectors, you
give me back the Graham-Schmidt
orthonormal basis,
and we'll see how to
express that in matrix form.
OK.
So let me give you
the two vectors.
So I'll take the vector A
equals let's say one, one, one,
why not?
And B equals let's say
one, zero, two, OK?
I didn't want to cheat
and make them orthogonal
in the first place because
then Graham-Schmidt
wouldn't be needed.
OK.
So those are not orthogonal.
So what is capital A?
Well that's the same as big A.
That was fine.
What's B?
So B is this b --
is the original B,
and then I subtract off
some multiple of the A.
And what's the multiple?
What goes in here?
B -- here's the A -- this is
the -- this is the little b,
this is the big A, also
the little a, and I want
to multiply it by that
right -- that right ratio,
which has A transpose
A, here's my ratio.
I'm just doing this.
So it's A transpose B,
what is A transpose B,
it looks like three.
And what is A -- oh, my --
what's A transpose A?
Three.
I'm sorry.
I didn't know that
was going to happen.
OK.
But it happened.
Why should we knock it?
OK.
So do you see it all right?
That's A transpose B,
there's A transpose A, that's
the fraction, so
I take this away,
and I get one take away one
is a zero, zero minus this one
is a minus one, and two
minus the one is a one.
OK.
And what's this vector
that we finally found?
This is B.
And how do I know it's right?
How do I know I've
got a vector I want?
I check that B is
perpendicular to --
that A and B are perpendicular.
That A is perpendicular to B.
Just look at that.
That one -- the dot product
of that with that is zero.
OK.
So now what is my q1 and q2?
Why don't I put
them in a matrix?
Of course.
Since I'm always putting
these -- so the Q,
I'll put the q1 and
the q2 in a matrix.
And what are they?
Now when I'm writing
q-s I'm supposed
to make things normalized.
I'm supposed to make
things unit vectors.
So I'm going to take that A
but I'm going to divide it
by square root of three.
And I'm going to
take this B but I'm
going to divide it
by square root of two
to make it a unit vector,
and there is my matrix.
That's my matrix with
orthonormal columns coming from
Graham-Schmidt and
it sort of it --
it came from the original
one, one, one, one, zero, two,
right?
That was my original guys.
These were the two
I started with.
These are the two that
I'm happy to end with.
Because those are orthonormal.
So that's what
Graham-Schmidt did.
It -- well, tell me about
the column spaces of these
matrices.
How is the column space of Q
related to the column space of
A?
So I'm always asking
you things like this,
and that makes you think,
OK, the column space
is all combinations of the
columns, it's that plane,
right?
I've got two vectors in
three-dimensional space,
their column space is a plane,
the column space of this matrix
is a plane, what's the
relation between the planes?
Between the two column spaces?
They're one and the same, right?
It's the same column space.
All I'm taking is here this
B thing that I computed,
this B thing that I computed
is a combination of B and A,
and A was little A, so
I'm always working here
with this in the same space.
I'm just like getting
ninety-degree angles in there.
Where my original column space
had a perfectly good basis,
but it wasn't as
good as this basis,
because it wasn't orthonormal.
Now this one is orthonormal,
and I have a basis then that --
so now projections, all the
calculations I would ever want
to do are -- are a cinch
with this orthonormal basis.
One final point.
One final point in this chapter.
And it's -- just
like elimination.
We learned how to
do elimination,
we know all the
steps, we can do it.
But then I came back to it and
said look at it as a matrix
in matrix language and
elimination gave me --
what was elimination
in matrix language?
I'll just put it up there.
A was LU.
That was matrix,
that was elimination.
Now, I want to do the
same for Graham-Schmidt.
Everybody who works
in linear algebra
isn't going to write
out the columns
are orthogonal, or orthonormal.
And isn't going to write
out these formulas.
They're going to write out the
connection between the matrix A
and the matrix Q.
And the two matrices have
the same column space,
but there's some -- some
matrix is taking the --
and I'm going to call it R, so
A equals QR is the magic formula
here.
It's the expression
of Graham-Schmidt.
And I'll -- let me
just capture that.
So that's the -- my final
step then is A equal QR.
Maybe I can squeeze it in here.
So A has columns,
let's say a1 and a2.
Let me suppose n is
two, just two vectors.
OK.
So that's some
combination of q1 and q2.
And times some matrix R.
They have the same column space.
This is just -- this matrix just
includes in it whatever these
numbers like three over three
and one over square root
of three and one over
square root of two,
probably that's what it's got.
One over square root of three,
one over square root of two,
something there, but actually
it's got a zero there.
So the main point about
this A equal QR is this R
turns out to be
upper triangular.
It turns out that this
zero is upper triangular.
We could see why.
Let me see, I can put in
general formulas for what these
This I think in here should
be the inner product of a1
with q1. are.
And this one should be the --
the inner product of a1 with q2.
And that's what I
believe is zero.
This will be something here,
and this will be something here
with inner -- a1 transpose q2,
sorry a2 transpose q1 and a2
transpose q2.
But why is that guy zero?
Why is a1 q2 zero?
That's the key to this being
-- this R here being upper
triangular.
You know why a1q2 is
zero, because a1 --
that was my --
this was really a and b here.
This was really a and b.
So this is a transpose q2.
And the whole point of
Graham-Schmidt was that we
constructed these later q-s to
be perpendicular to the earlier
vectors, to the earlier --
all the earlier vectors.
So that's why we get
a triangular matrix.
The -- result is
extremely satisfactory.
That if I have a matrix
with independent columns,
the Graham-Schmidt
produces a matrix
with orthonormal columns, and
the connection between those
is a triangular matrix.
That last point, that the
connection is a triangular
matrix, please look
in the book, you
have to see that one more time.
OK.
Thanks, that's great.